[музика]
подорож в інший світ займає лише
півхвилини 30 МТВ під землею підземне
містечко
Гельсінкі Лабіринт із тунелів та
підземних приміщень має захистити 900
000 людей від ракетних ударів хімічної
зброї та радіоактивного випромінювання
на випадок війни А ще куку
куку Ласкаво просимо на один з
найулюбленіших ігрових майданчиків
Гельсінки длярі віку хокейне поле та
тренажерний зал їдальня та автостоянка
як бонус дехто навіть святкує тут свої
дні народження для нас це повсякденне
життя Ми виросли з цим бомбосховищем для
нас У цьому немає нічого незвичайного Ми
навіть не замислюємося про це у всьому
Гельсінкі повно таких підземних світів
цей бункер У центральному районі
Гельсінки хаканіємі один з найбільших у
фінській столиці за словами представника
цивільної оборони Томі раска у
приміщенні могли б розміститися два
футбольні
стадіони однак у разі війни центр
дозвілля у найкоротший термін здатний
перетворитися на повноцінне
бомбосховище звичайним сценарієм є
використання притулку від кількох годин
до кількох днів у більшості притулків ми
можемо продовжити цей
час але тривале перебування тут буде
пов'язане з усілякими труднощами
приміром тепло яке виділяє Людське тіло
тільки один Я безперервно виділяє
близько 100 Вт
тепла проживання 6 000 людей у такому
закритому просторі- велика проблема але
не в гельснки місто стоїть на плиті з
граніту та гнейсу бункер розміщується в
підземній Скелі порода якої не тільки
стійка але й має охолоджувальний
ефект до того ж великі зали у разі
потреби можна швидко переобладнати у
безліч невеликих
приміщень Таким чином тисячі людей
можуть жити тут під землею впродовж
тривалого
часу тут люди помиратимуть
народжуватимуться хворітимуть тут будуть
щасливі та сумні люди просто життя
нормального суспільства лише вередині
укриття Фінляндія має 1 км спільного
дуну з Росією країна багато десятиліть
відмовлялася від вступу в НАТО а шпуки
не почалася повномасштабна війна в
Україні ось уже півроку як Фінляндія
стала членом НАТО війна Росії в Україні
змінила мешканців країни Більшість хоче
більшого захисту більшої безпеки
ми і фіни схильні ставитися до всього
цього стоїчно ми знаємо що цей ризик
існував завжди відколи Фінляндія стала
незалежною він проявився під час Другої
світової війни коли Радянський Союз
намагався завоювати нашу країну і одного
разу Це може статися знову ми знаємо про
це але не думаємо про це щодня І не
боїмося
цього тепер на тлі нової війни в Європі
події радянсько-фінської війни
1939-40 років постають в іншому світлі
фіни тоді змогли відстояти свою
незалежність проте за це їм довелося
заплатити високу ціну та поступитися
частиною своєї території Московський
мирний договір
1940 року став одним із підсумків цього
похмурого розділу у відносинах між двома
країнами про ці події нагадує пам'ятник
у центрі Гельсінки під час тієї як її
називають у Фінляндії зимової Війни було
ухвалено перший закон про цивільну
оборону відтоді діє норма що всі
громадські споруди а також приватні
будинки починаючи з певних розмірів
повинні мати свої укриття і метро також
загалом лише у Гельсінки налічується
понад 5 000 бомбосховищ розрахованих
майже на мільйон
людей ми виконуємо свою роботу в Надії
що нам це ніколи не знадобиться але ми
все одно повинні це робити Історія вчить
нас що якщо щось не виключено то це може
статися жителі гельснки бути готовими до
цього і завжди мати можливість сховатися
від небезпеки на глибині 30 м під своїм
містом